[Música]
hace un tiempo un par de años
un día me encontré con un amigo muy
cerca de fin de año las fiestas navidad
y estamos charlando y él me cuenta que
había estado en una tienda de libros y
que en la fila para que les en paquete
en las cosas que estaban comprando había
un muchacho digamos unos 17 18 años que
estaba llevando un libro mismo
y en ese entonces tenía dos libros
publicados de los cuales ninguno había
sido reseñado habían sido dulcemente
ignorados cada vez que iba a una tienda
de libros veía que estaban allí en las
estanterías acumulando polvo entonces yo
me estaba cuestionando mucho esta idea
de ser escritor para que es el escritor
porque es el escritor
[Música]
entonces con este miedo me cuenta está
este hecho yo agarro en mi mente una
historia
ok esta persona que estaba comprando un
libro mío llamémosle manuel estaba
comprando este libro para regalar a
alguien
ahora los libros no son regalos estándar
como chocolates o como bolígrafos que se
nos pueden dar a cualquier persona los
libros por lo general se regalan alguien
a quien conocemos y que sabemos que le
gusta leer estudio que hay menor estaba
comprando este libro para alguien de su
familia algún amigo o amiga alguna
persona que le gustara y seguramente
esta persona en algún momento lo había
mostrado a manuel algún texto que le
gustaba quizás un poema
quizás un poema que era triste que era
obsceno que era mal hablado entonces
cuando manuel va a la tienda de libros y
comienza a ver lo que había y de
casualidad toma mi libro comienza a
hojearlo y descubre que ya no uno sino
muchos poemas tristes obscenos y mal
hablados entonces dice ok este es para
esa persona
[Música]
con este nido de cuentas de historia e
inventó toda esta versión que quizás no
es cierta pero me gusta creerla
y comienza a entender el parque güell
porque yo había decidido querer ser
escritor cuando era niño iba al colegio
y bueno pues tiene que pasar ahí 5 horas
encerrado de lunes a viernes sin poder
hacer nada ni siquiera poder ir al baño
eran 25 horas a la semana es mucho
tiempo perdían mucho tiempo entonces yo
buscaba la forma de distraerme
en esa época los celulares no eran tan
cool como ahora no habían smartphones
entonces lo máximo que tú puedes esperar
un celular era tener uno o dos juegos
que andan monótonos que los 10 minutos
ya te aburrirás
yo tenía un
consola portátil de videojuegos pero mi
mamá la guardaba muy bien porque en el
colegio tenían la regla la novedad de
que no se podía llevar artefactos
electrónicos entonces la consola estaba
muy bien guardada no podía llevarla no
era una opción para distraer hoy en día
le agradezco a mi mamá que he hecho eso
no probé hacer la regla que era absurda
sino porque gracias a eso pude acercarme
más a los libros ya la música si me
gustaba leer desde que era niño estudié
música pero
no me sentía tan cercano entonces ante
esa situación donde yo buscaba
distraerme agarro y descubro los libros
y me acerco más a la música así que lo
que yo hacía estaba en el curso y ponía
el libro de la materia que estuviera
pasando al frente y por detrás ponía
otro libro que estuviera leyendo aparte
me llevaba un reproductor de estos mp3
que eran como un flash super grandote
que servía para escuchar música también
entonces ponía eso en el bolsillo pasaba
el cable del audífono por debajo de la
txanpa por la manga y lo ponía así en mi
cabeza para que pareciera que estaba
descansando la cabeza mientras atendía
clases cuando en verdad estaba
escuchando música y leyendo un libro
por alguna extraña razón esta forma de
distraerme comenzó a hacerme sentir muy
cómodo yo comencé a sentirme bastante
cómodo leyendo estas historias
escuchando esas canciones
y curiosamente me sentía incluso más
cómodo haciendo esto que hablando con
mis compañeros yo sí tenía amigos
hablaba con gente pero era muy pocas
personas con las cuales yo realmente
podía hablar con la mayoría de las
personas era un acto muy mecánico era
responder era un intercambio de
información
que realmente no decían nada como cuando
subes al minibús o al trufa y dices
buenos días en verdad no estás diciendo
buenos días no estás deseando buenos
días no te importa cómo están los días
de esas personas simplemente días buenos
días y ya porque es lo que te enseñaron
que digas entonces para mí hablar con
mis compañeros será algo más o menos así
a muy pocas personas pero curiosamente
cuando yo leí estas historias si sentía
cierta empatía me sentía más conectado y
eso era raro porque yo tenía muy pocas
cosas en común con estas personas eran
personas que habían vivido o que vivían
muy lejos
bueno muchas de ellas incluso estaban
muertas muy muertas entonces tenía
muchas más cosas en común con mis
compañeros en teoría pero aún así yo me
sentía más cercano a estas otras
personas
bueno el tiempo fue pasando en algún
momento
yo igual como otra forma de distraerme
comencé a
y qué tal si yo intento hacer esto
entonces conveniente para escribir
comencé a intentar componer ahí descubrí
que la composición no era lo mío estaba
bien a veces pasa pero con la escritura
parecía irme bien me sentía cómodo
entonces comencé a grabar mis propios
cuadernos como otra forma de distracción
tampoco he entendido muy bien lo que
decía
bueno pasa el tiempo en algún momento
tenemos que comenzar a preguntarnos qué
vamos a hacer más adelante la primera
pregunta siempre es qué quiere decir
cuando seas grande y allí hay una gama
de respuestas muy amplias porque no
puedes y yo quiero ser deportista yo
quiero ser actor yo quiero ser
presidente yo quiero ser astronauta hay
una gama muy amplia de opciones y hoy
dije quiero ser escritor
no sabía muy bien por qué pero me
gustaba hacerlo entonces y quiero ser
escritor
en la medida que pasa el tiempo la gama
de respuesta se va reduciendo porque la
pregunta cambia ya no es que quiere ser
como seres grandes que vas a estudiar
con esta proteína del colegio ya hay que
ir pisando tierra entonces ya no se
trata de que te gustaría saber sino que
hay qué opciones tiene es por cuál va a
optar pero yo vi hill seguía con la idea
de no y que es el escritor y seguía y
seguía dando vueltas con eso pajareando
y claro eso ya me pone un poco fuera del
lugar porque la mayoría de mis
compañeros ya estaban pensando en
carreras universidades comparando
península estaba en otra
pero tenía como que la comodidad de
todavía tenía los libros la música y me
sentía cómodo de hecho con el tiempo yo
fui descubriendo otras formas de poder
comunicarme con estas personas
aparentemente tan lejanas descubrir el
cine descubrí al teatro descubrió la
pintura tienen como que nuevos puentes
que iba formando
bueno tiempos y yo pasando cosas de la
vida termina entrando en la universidad
en una carrera
y ahí pues la cosa no pareció mejorar
porque ahí la pregunta igual al inicio
es en qué áreas de tu carrera a la que
sea que fuera te gustaría especializar
entonces hay uno dice mira esta me
parece interesante esto me llama la
atención yo seguía no pero en la medida
en que el tiempo sigue pasando
nuevamente la pregunta cambia y
nuevamente la gama de respuesta se
reduce porque ya no se trata de qué área
te interesa no se trata de en qué vas a
trabajar cómo está el mercado laboral
cómo está el tema de los sueldos
entonces nuevamente vuelve a pisar más
tierra
pero yo seguía no yo quiero esto
entonces
esa sensación de fuera del lugar esa
sensación de ser es ubicado y va siendo
cada vez más fuerte
con excepción claro de cuando yo leía
cuando yo vi una película cuando
escuchar una canción una sinfonía lo que
fuera porque yo ahí sentía de ti ser de
conexión sentía más empatía normalmente
con esas personas tan lejanas en teoría
y en apariencia tan tan lejanas pero al
mismo tiempo tan cercanas
entonces ello comienza a entender a lo
que pasa es que estas personas también
estuvieron fuera de lugar todas esas
personas todos los que decidieron tener
estos intereses
diferentes quizás a los que la mayoría
tiene también fueron desubicados en su
momento en su contexto también tuvieron
que lidiar con las situaciones del día a
día con las imposibilidades cosas
cotidianas y aún así siguieron haciendo
lo que decidieron que querían hacer
cuando yo estaba pensando en que voy a
hablar hoy la gente de la organización
me decía con tu charla con lo que sea
que digas tienes que llegar a por lo
menos una persona que esté aquí hoy
y yo sé que acá hay no una sino muchas
personas que están están conformes están
satisfechas con las decisiones que han
tomado se sienten bien con las
profesiones que han elegido con la
carrera que están estudiando se sienten
bien
y estás súper de verdad genial
pero
hay otros que quizás no y quizás se
sienten fuera del lugar bueno a los del
primer grupo a los que están conformes
perdón les roba como 10 minutos de su
tiempo pero esta charla no es para
ustedes
no se preocupen yo he perdido dos años
de mi colegio y sting con la universidad
escuchando cosas que no eran para mí así
que conozco el sentimiento
pero para nosotros
y simplemente decirles qué
no son no están tan solos
durante gran parte de la historia en
prácticamente todo el mundo han habido
no una sino muchas personas que se
sentían iguales fuera del lugar
que igual tenían estas dudas de pucha
porque me gusta esto tenía estos
intereses diferentes un poco más
ingenuos quizás y que aún así siguieron
haciendo lo que decidieron hacer por
muchas razones pero una de las razones
que a mí me gusta creer que ellos tenían
era justamente para poder comunicarse
con estos otros fuera del lugar para
poder ir dejando a través de su obra a
través de sus creaciones esas pequeñas
migajas como un rastro para que otros
puedan encontrar el camino
la historia de manuel comprando un libro
mío me hizo entender eso que era para
eso para lo que yo quería ser escritor
está bien que te reseñen está bien ganar
premios y cosas así pero eso no debería
ser la razón principal no es un
principal debería ser que tú puedes
comunicarte con otras personas y decirle
sabes no estás tan fuera de lugar o al
menos si estás fuera de lugar no eres el
único gracias
[Aplausos]